why does everybody keep on hiring me all
of my work is hello I'm the
Nostalgia Critic guy remembered so you
don't have to well seeing how we just
started Shama one month it only figures
to ask the question how do good
directors go bad yes it's easy to point
at Shyamalan as a prime example of this
seeing how one of his earliest films The
Sixth Sense was a huge huge hit and his
movies got increasingly worse after but
what about the others you know who I'm
talking about
directors that even today are praised as
maverick game changers but many people
few have lost their touch in later years
is it just an inevitable part of getting
older are all artists doomed to fail if
they stay around too long it's a
question a lot of people who love movies
have been asking for years well the best
way to look at this is probably in
groups so let's start off by looking at
the group you most likely want to hear
the most about the ones that went
completely downhill the SHA Millan's the
George Lucas is the Wachowski the
directors we thought were going to
change the world but then somewhere down
the line went completely south what do
all these directors have in common well
a couple of things surprisingly all of
them we declared we're gonna keep making
great things if that one thing they made
was amazing surely all the other ones
afterwards will be just as amazing if
not greater brighter Ralph Ellison wrote
a novel called visible men in 1952 it
was so good and so praised by everyone
around him that he never wrote another
novel again he became a perfectionist
and the pressure of following up such a
masterwork intimidated him so much that
he never released another one that's
just one example of how certain
attention can get in the way of good
progress when George Lucas made Star
Wars people were blown away saying it
would change film forever and in some
respects it did every big blockbuster is
trying to do what star wars did whether
in style or the amount of people they're
trying to attract but if you look at a
lot of the deleted scenes and original
scripts you'll find that a lot of it was
very similar to the now despised
prequels there were a lot of political
talks there were a lot of pointless sea
and admit it some of the dialogue has an
eerie corniness of what was to come
years later I recognized your foul
stench when I was brought on board
couldn't you just hear that alongside
either choice presents great danger
tears all but one of the things was he
had people giving him advice telling him
what would probably work in what
wouldn't he wasn't a star yet and a lot
was riding on this film so why not
listen this is possibly what helped make
this movie such a big game-changer but
even early on the signs were there after
the first run of the film Lucas
immediately went back in put episode 4
in the opening scroll so as much as
people like to say he's changing things
in altering the film's only recently
they were done when they were first
shown and remember that Empire and Jedi
were not directed by him and the scenes
that people have the most problems with
are usually the ones he pushed the
heaviest so years of not directing a
film not really doing that much
storytelling and nobody talking against
him but instead praising him as a genius
can we really be shocked we got what we
got history repeated itself almost
identically with the Matrix movies
though Chesky started off with a pretty
damn good first movie but then hit mega
blockbuster status when they directed
the matrix much like Star Wars it had
groundbreaking effects an interesting
style and an environment that allowed
for a lot of interpretation
so knowing Hollywood what happened the
exact same thing except faster they
wanted two more Matrix movies bigger and
better than the original telling the
Wachowskis to do whatever they wanted
but as we learn with Lucas doing
whatever you want isn't always the
answer though chess keys also had to
take advice on their first movie and as
I pointed out in my review it's not like
the writing was exactly perfect you
might say every man Moon person of Jesus
Christ
subtle but now imagine that writing with
nobody advising them and instead of fan
base praising that their words are
incredible I get lost and out deep they
are like Lucas the following movies
reflected that trying to make the world
seem more vast and meaningful while
forgetting to focus on basic essentials
like enjoyable characters or a coherent
story but think about it if you were a
writer
rector in that situation what possibly
happened to you two even directors are
still popular like Christopher Nolan
it's totally understandable how people
can still like his work but even his
strongest fans are starting to notice a
little repeat a lot of philosophical
talk resulting in a very long running
time leading to a super complicated
story now these are criticisms that have
always been in his movies all of them
the Mentos Batman Begins inception these
films had very similar patterns some
claim it's the same thing over and over
in they're sick of it
others claim that doesn't matter because
he just does it so well but everybody
agrees they've seen it a lot the point
is sometimes it's not giving us
something different that's a noticeable
problem sometimes it's just giving us
the exact same thing but not all
directors are given almost complete
creative freedom look at horror
directors like John Carpenter and the
late Wes Craven both of them start off
with creative ideas and promising
careers but somewhere they started to
feel a little stale after Halloween John
Carpenter directed almost a movie a year
and most of them were awesome and badass
but then they start to go on repeat we
were seeing stuff we felt we saw before
except not as innovative he basically
left directing and instead soaks up the
praise of his past projects which given
his age and how much cool stuff he's
done that seems fitting enough but as
much as people praised Wes Craven after
his passing they usually forget he's
kind of been on the decline for years as
well sure we know him for his early work
but aside from the screen movies which
even mocked itself and how lame it was
getting he hasn't made that many films
that people remember one of the reasons
maybe Wes Craven didn't want to do
horror ever notice a few romantic films
snuck their way in there that's because
he always wanted to do love stories but
after the success of his scary films he
was labeled as the master of horror for
a while and that seemed to be what kept
him popular as well as continue to get
him work he even made fun of this in
scream 3 when the director admits he
doesn't even like doing horror films and
instead want to do romances he managed
to get one or two in there but can we
really be shocked they're not all his
scary movies are masterpieces when it
wasn't even his original
and there is also a group of directors
that don't make that many good movies
because they don't make that many movies
in general the legendary Francis Ford
Coppola clearly just kind of directs
whatever he wants we all know him for
the Godfather films and Apocalypse Now
but did you know he also directed
Captain EO or fairytale theater or Peggy
Sue got married or Jack what do you like
these are not you have to admit these
are rather strange choices for a guy
like this the part of it is
understandable because he's been busy
with other stuff from producing to
theater work to freaking winemaking he
seems like a guy who likes to do a lot
just not all in one field but when you
do that the chances of making constantly
good films are usually lessened as
you're simply not making them as much
but then again if he's happy he's happy
who says he has to keep making films to
appease us Liam freakin went from
directing something every year to every
three years and half the time it wasn't
even movies it was TV and even then the
choices were usually very odd and not
winning over that many critics or
audiences but to his credit
it was those bizarre choices that gave
us masterpieces like The Exorcist or
live and die in LA and so forth
sometimes that weird style can peak at
just the right time but then not really
be ready for a different generation bug
for example I'll film about a couple
going crazy from paranoia would it work
great in the 70s but today most
audiences just find it annoying and
confusing neither opinion is right or
wrong but timing is everything when it
comes to making popular art which comes
to the next group of directors you see
quite often the hit or miss directors
these are the directors who used to make
nothing but hits but suddenly make
misses that are so bad you can't
possibly believe they were from the same
person Tim Burton used to be a unique
visionary with Ed Wood Batman and Edward
Scissorhands
but then films like Mars Attacks Dark
Shadows and plan of the apes are part of
his lineup too angly was well known for
losing his path in a big way once in a
while Gus Van Sant seems to go back and
forth between making unknowingly
unfocused arthouse experiments and
reasonably good films at the same time
Robert Zemeckis walks the tightrope both
literally and
figuratively with giants like back to
the future and Roger Rabbit
but then backfires with what lies
beneath and contact Robert Rodriguez is
amazing in how back and forth he goes
with the likability or hain ability of
his movies most recently we seen really
Scott practically Lampoon his own style
with Robin Hood and Prometheus but
within one film went back everybody with
the Martian what do all these directors
have in common well they all have pretty
extreme styles as much as we love the
extremes people forget they can just as
easily backfire as hit bull's eyes the
style of these filmmakers though seems
to be just relatable enough that even
when they do make a big Mis we're still
willing to jump right back on because
they can still make a connection with us
that seems timeless it's hard to say
what the secret is that keeps us coming
back to them but all of them have it in
their own unique way which brings us to
the most impressive group of directors
who have gone bad the ones who come back
remember when the Coen brothers made a
long line of bad films they returned to
pleasing us and as strange as ever
remember when Woody Allen suffered an
embarrassing personal life as well as
creative life he retaliated with
intelligent comedies that even had a
hint of magic to them berry Santa fellas
making bomb after bomb but then he may
men in black 3 the surprising sequel
that nobody knew they wanted master
filmmakers like Steven Spielberg and
Martin Scorsese both giants of cinema in
their own unique way veered into a long
stream of disappointment but found
themselves making great work again in
completely new ways and yes even
Shyamalan has made a little bit of a
comeback with the visit getting both
critical and box-office praised these
are directors that started off strong
veered into dark path and then seemingly
came out creatively rejuvenated did they
just need time to heal did they need to
try something new to discover the old
ways or were the old ways getting the
way of something new honestly we can't
know for sure and it's all subjective
really this is just speculation
we can't know for sure what's going on
behind the scenes any more than we can
know what's going on inside somebody's
head everything listed here are
possibilities that seem likely but
aren't certain I guess what I'm trying
to get to is that there's no perfect way
to make continually great art everyone's
going to have their ups and downs some
stay down
others come back up and many hover
somewhere in between with filmmaking
requiring as many people as it does
there's no one method that's proven to
always work sometimes the studio gets in
the way other times they save a movie
sometimes an artist should be allowed to
do whatever they want other times they
need more restraint you can never know
for sure but honestly that's what makes
art so exciting there is no one answer
it can come from any style anywhere from
anyone will Shyamalan ride the success
of the visit into better work or was it
just a lucky shot in the dark
nobody knows and thank God for it the
unpredictability of what a product is
going to do is part of what makes it so
thrilling a well-known director can make
rap and a well-known bad director can
make gold so just remember when it comes
to art there is no certainty and you
don't have all the answers none of us do
it's just interesting to speculate and
guess to help figure out what can make
something better there's nothing wrong
with that as long as you always remember
it's just speculation
so keep experimenting keep discovering
and keep an open mind for where the next
is in Caine or the room could possibly
come from
Aylin missed out your great again don't
worry I won't be this fair the rest of
the month
hey sorry for the handheld here I left
my tripod a at the office but that's not
way why hear about you I hear what the
charity shoutout is this week and you
can thank rob paulsen for his
introduction to this charity without him
I want to found out about this this is
boot campaign boot campaign is trying to
raise awareness for veterans people that
have gone to war people that have served
as people who put their lives in danger
people have sacrificed so much the
campaign helps raise awareness of their
sacrifice through the image of boots
their big question is why do you wear
your boots people go online and share
their stories about why the soldiers who
have served us mean so much to us and as
you imagine it isn't just buying boots
and showing support it's going online
and donating and one of the great things
is that they show where the money is
going this is an organization has gotten
all sorts of celebrities on board like I
said rob paulsen but also the sons of
anarchy cast this is a great idea to
raise awareness for people who
definitely deserve it
the bravery and the dedication that
these soldiers put forward is
mind-blowing and you can show your
support by either going to the website
or even going to their YouTube page and
seeing all the various stories you can
volunteer you can donate or you can just
wear your boots which are also available
to purchase on the website and help
raise awareness and show support get
online and tell everybody why you wear
your boots